home grant chaps hello to you mr champs
always great to see you thanks for
joining us do you think the queen was
talking about you and yours
well i i think um you know comments made
in in private should stay in private but
i think we all share the desire to see
progress made and
we know that there'll be you know
hundreds of leaders coming to glasgow
for cop um we will wait to see whether
it all lives up to you know they all
live up to the expectations it's very
important that we get this job done
yeah she was at a public event not a
private event um yes i don't think her
comments
talks and does nothing do you think
she's talking about the government
well she specifically referred to who
was coming actually so i don't think it
was
i don't think it was intended in that
sense but nonetheless as i said she made
the comments not intending it to be
overheard but i think everybody feels
that uh you know we want to make sure
there's progress and there's there's
been a lot of progress of course it
remains to be seen
at cop 26 um the extent to which the
world commits but the uk has uh led the
way on this first country in the world
to legislate for getting to zero carbon
by 2050 and and we're all doing a lot of
work to try to get there
britain should prioritize economic
growth over environmental protections in
trade deals according to elite
government report
yeah that's not that's not correct and
actually it's not what's actually
happening either because i mean even if
you take for example
the work being done with australia
there's an entire chapter on
environmental uh protection so um you
know the proof is in the eating with
these things i i don't recognize that at
all
uh environmental safeguards should also
not be treated as a red line when other
countries demand they are broken in
trade agreements according to officials
in the department of international trade
well as i say i mean i think australia
is probably the finest example you could
find that that's a country where um has
been widely reported there's still quite
a long way to go when it comes to
decarbonization they're using a lot of
coal and and so on haven't gone down the
track that we've already gone down but
even in that trade agreement uh as i say
entire chapter on exactly this issue so
i i i that's not that's not the case
in reality uh environmental protections
are being put right now any of those
comments um
exclusive uh report that we had from our
sam coats last night well let's just say
proof is in the eating and uh even with
a country which isn't as far down the
the decarbonization track as us we put
it at the heart of the uh of the of the
agreement
okay so that report is
the details of that uh report um are
wrong let's see why experience
details is they tend to be pretty
selective okay but you know
let's see and thank you for offering
your view on that this morning let me
ask you about your view on um if the
leader of china doesn't come to cop 26
isn't it just a talking shop and a waste
of time
well there's already been a huge number
of um commitments and you know including
the
leader of the president of the united
states uh coming uh
you know huge number of people who will
be coming a lot of uh time and energy
gone into
reducing
carbon and people making pledges and
even with
china we've seen for example them
recently
pledged not to support more money going
into building coals overseas not in
china but the the money they they put
into coal stations being built elsewhere
so that is a big move of course but we
need them to do that domestically of
course they need to decarbonize and
they've set their own um targets to
decarbonize uh nationally as well of
course we want them there we want
everybody there um but uh let let let's
see uh who comes and you know the
success the world can can make of this
it's clearly important that that we do
but it doesn't matter to us if they
don't come
well i look after you i just said of
course we want them to come um i i can't
go around each individual leader and
tell you exactly what their travel plans
i mean
you can't really compare a small third
world country to somebody like china the
chinese don't come uh and so don't buy
into cop 26.
it's blowing out the water well i don't
think you can call america or the
entirety of europe the small third world
countries um absolutely most world is
coming i don't if countries don't come
there'll be the outliers rather than um
central to this and most countries i
think want to be relevant in this
okay talk to me about uh toys turkeys
and pigs in blankets all in short supply
you've got days we're told by the
industry uh rather than weeks to save
christmas what are you doing about it
yeah well look we we know that the globe
has woken up uh following coronavirus
there's huge kind of supply chain issues
everywhere around the entirety around in
the entire world um but in this country
we've taken 24 now 25 different steps on
the domestic side of that that's that's
the lorry driver side of things and
we're seeing it having a big impact
we've got now three times as many people
applying to become lorry drivers every
single day than we have before the
crisis i think we've got to be very
careful not to you know we mustn't try
and report ourselves into a crisis in
fact uh the ports are operating under
plenty of pressure uh but i was speaking
to for example felix stowe last night
that's the biggest container port
in the country
and they were saying yeah you know only
one time there may be a ship out at sea
uh waiting to to dock
in los angeles they have about 60 ships
out at sea waiting to dock at any one
time it's very much a global thing and
it's being managed pretty resiliently
here
yeah but i'm just asking what we are
doing to fix it because sure
my understanding is that um lorry
drivers that you're trying to get in
from europe
the rules that you're going to put in
place you've relaxed those rules but
it's going to take several weeks for
that to happen uh butchers um who are
going to come in from the continent that
is going to take several weeks and they
still have to speak good english in
order to get here meanwhile we're seeing
panic buying in the shops shop shelves
are empty and the supermarkets are
putting things like ketchup where the
fridges are to try and make it look busy
well first of all the measures that i'm
taking today are called cabotage this is
where
a lorry driver from overseas
can come here at the moment uh the rule
is they can only make two pickups and
drops within seven days once they're
here
domestically within the uk cabotage
means that uh within a two week period
they'll be able to make unlimited number
of pickups and drops that's the
equivalent of adding thousands of extra
lorry drivers to the road but we don't
have to do anything with visas in order
to do this it's a straightforward
measure it will come in towards the end
of the year it's one additional measure
to the 24 that i've already uh or as a
government we've already introduced uh
to make sure that things are flowing as
i say uh there's evidence that that's
working you will have um noted that the
queues of the petrol pumps have gone
that we've got more people applying to
come lorry drivers are more tests
available than we have before
coronavirus for people to pass yeah
they're hgb understood mr sorry um but
but my point was you said end of the
year the the industry is saying needs to
be the end of next week so a lot of
these measures are already in place um
and some of them have already started to
say expand the number of places
available for tests uh and relax a whole
series i i don't think we've got time to
go through all 25 of them um but
they are on my twitter page if anyone
want is interested and these are having
an impact and it's enabling people to be
able to uh get goods and services around
in what i say is a global uh shortage um
perhaps you you might say well why is it
so extreme well this economy is growing
the fastest of all those in the group of
seven the g7 economies which means that
uh you know the pressures are of course
very real but people will be able to get
things for christmas uh these are these
measures are having an impact they're
loosening things up and as i say when i
talk to the ports they're saying yes
it's busy it's a globally busy picture
but if you compared us with what's
happening in many other ports around the
world um
we we need to keep this in proportion
thing things are flowing christmas is
safe i get it you're promising christmas
is safe um no grinch at christmas um in
the shaps household uh well that's so
pleased to hear that let me ask you
about something else if i may i put this
to your colleagues
and he was telling i was i was on
holiday last week and i was with um a
lorry driver and he said one of the ways
to have a quick fix is
hgv drivers in the army can drive at 17
hgv trucks you can't do that on silly
street until you're 21. he said a lot of
road haulage and they come up through
the family business and they want to be
road hauling drivers and they have to
have that four year wait unless they go
into the army to drive trucks there
is that something that you will look at
yeah sorry in my last sentence i was
going to say uh with christmas last year
we were worried about being able to see
loved ones and families um there'd be no
issues with that this year
and we'll make sure that the supply
chain is is doing uh what it should be
doing which is what these measures that
we're taking including alterations to
this cabotage today is designed to do
and on truck drivers um look i i'm very
i'm very up for things which make it
possible for people to get into the
business and that's why i've changed the
law and i'm changing the law in a whole
variety of ways including making testing
much more streamlined simplification and
some of some of the additional things
that we're able to do
for passing driving tests that we
couldn't do whilst we were in the eu
that we've been able to go back to
pre-1997
rules which were introduced by the eu
commission at the time that made it
harder for people to be qualified as
lorry drivers so i'll look at
everything
actually on this issue of uh how old you
have to be to to drive a an hdb i'll
certainly have a look at that and please
thank your lorry driver friend for the
for the idea i'll look at anything which
is going to make things easier
i'm sure he'll be thrilled he's watching
in portugal this morning i told you i'd
ask him steve let's see what happens as
a result why do
butchers who come over from europe have
to be able to speak good english
because this is part of you know we've
left the eu we're now able to uh make
sure that we have control over who comes
here and for what purpose and one of the
visa routes the main visa route rather
is that people have to be able to
speak the language have a skill
which is not domestically available have
a guarantee of certain earnings so that
they're not reliant on the taxpayer the
the you know the the points based system
and we've been able to pass that into
law um what we want to do is invest in
brits make sure that we're training up
british workers make sure that we're
automating investing in technologies and
making ourselves more productive and
it's something the economy hasn't done
for years we've constantly whether it's
lorry drivers or people in farming being
prepared to undercut people domestically
rather than invest in people with a high
skill high wage economy and that's what
we're we're moving to here yeah although
you know it looks as though brits don't
want to cut up pigs for the public to
eat and we've got uh europeans who will
come and do that they might not just
have as good english as somebody in
wall's end i don't why is that a problem
well
you know this country voted to take
control of its own borders and that's
what we're making we want we want the
best and most skilled people from around
the world we're very globally open we
welcome um people here from from all
around the world but we're going to do
that in a controlled way and say with
the with the visa test the regular visa
test one of the requirements is that um
people come in with um the skills but
also the language abilities uh in order
to take up those those visas and that's
that's you know we want we want people
domestically to be able to do those jobs
and of course the
the the the cheaper labor coming in over
many years stops
organizations from investing in
technology automating the way that we do
things it keeps productivity low we want
to be a high productivity highway i get
that i'm sorry we're almost out of time
mr shops and i've got two other things
to ask you about but i just want to
press you on that there's a hundred
thousand pigs that are about to be put
on pious because we haven't got enough
people to chop them up
so we actually today uh have included a
range of different different measures
including the amount of time and where
pigs can be
stored uh once slaughtered safely and uh
still be then uh used so um that's
actually the the visa thing is only one
part of a much wider package that i
suspect we haven't got time to run
through but nonetheless uh it is
designed to make sure that uh that
things are as smooth as they can be uh
as we go into this christmas period
let's counter very quickly onto pcr
tests should we you're going to change
the rules ahead of october half term
so that we're going to have lateral
flows rather than pcrs is what i should
say for day 2 testing
how will the photograph that you send in
to prove that you've had your test how
is that going to be verified
yeah there are two things that will be
required one is your book that test as
you would have done previously with the
pcr test whilst abroad so you'll have
the reference number and that will go in
your passenger locator form after you've
taken the test uh you take a snap of the
the test and upload it just as
confirmation that it's been taken it's
pretty straightforward and pretty quick
to do people be actually accustomed to
doing that a lot with the nhs tests
which you won't be able to take for the
purposes of holidays because that's a
sort of discretionary activity going
away by and large um but uh people will
be used to am i specifically sometimes
taking a second will it be verified how
are you going to verify that the picture
that you have relates to the person that
allegedly took it well we'll have look
you know in this world nothing is one
hundred percent uh but up till now we
haven't been requiring any verification
as we trust you gonna base it on trust
of course the system requires people to
be honest like so many laws in this
country that we ask people not to do
things and and put societal restrictions
on people and then we don't have a
policeman on every corner and every home
to make sure people aren't breaking the
laws of course